de 15 ans merci la parole l'état malam
vers gênés du beat müller
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
confirmé hier une prime supplémentaire
de 800 euros pour les enseignants du
premier degré ce qui représente un
alignement sur la prime que perçoivent
leurs collègues du second degré c'est
évidemment une bonne nouvelle pour les
330 mille professeurs des écoles
concernées dont les salaires sont
faibles mais c'est une moins bonne
nouvelle pour nos finances publiques
puisque cela représente une dépense
supplémentaire de près de 300 millions
d'euros
bien sûr non financées c'est vrai qu'en
matière éducative le gouvernement est
passé à côté de son quinquennat et vous
méritez un zéro pointé
nous avons eu la coûteuse réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui réunit la
contestation des enseignants
le ras-le-bol des maires et qui est
inadapté pour nos enfants
nous avons eu aussi la réforme du
collège qui soulève une contestation
significative des acteurs concernés
vos assises de la refondation pour
l'école consistait d'ailleurs uniquement
en un exercice d'auto salon de l'auto
satisfaction
cette prime ressemble donc à un baroud
d'honneur pour sauver une partie de
votre électorat
en réalité ce n'est qu'un paquet de plus
dans votre grand sac de cadeaux
électoraux depuis le début de l'année
avec la hausse du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires le plan de formation des
chômeurs le plan exceptionnel de soutien
l'élevage le plan en faveur de la
jeunesse
le fonds de soutien en faveur des
intermittents du spectacle au total
c'est plus de 5 milliards d'euros de
cash ou catégoriels annoncé qu'ils ne
sont en aucun cas financer quel français
peut se permettre de dépenser ce qu'il
n'a pas vous vous le faites monsieur le
premier ministre et le chéquier que vous
partagez avec le président de la
république n'a visiblement pas de limite
est cerise sur le gâteau électoral
vous préparez même une baisse d'impôt
pour 2017 alors que les français
paieront dans le même temps et pour la
première fois plus de 1000 milliards
d'euros de prélèvements obligatoires
cette nouvelle annonce n'est finalement
que la tentative désespérée de
reconquérir l'opinion mais les français
ne sont pas dupes
monsieur le premier ministre ouvrir les
vannes avant les élections est une
vieille manoeuvre ne croyez vous pas qu
après quatre ans de matraquage fiscal et
d'espoirs déçus sur tous les pans de
votre politique la ficelle est un peu
grosse
bien si la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre manuel valls
madame la députée génie du bi muller jeu
je vous réponds bien bien volontiers
parce que je crois c'est en effet
l'occasion d'ouvrir un débat est donc le
gouvernement fait des choix et des choix
justes et des choix que nous assumons et
que je veux assumer pleinement en vous
répondant oui nous avons choisi
d'augmenter l'indemnité annuelle de
suivi et d'accompagnement des élèves des
enseignants du primaire de 800 euros net
dès la rentrée prochaine
gelée annoncé hier madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale vient d'en
rappeler les modalités et nous assumons
ce choix parce que madame la députée les
enseignants de ce pays mérite d'être
pleinement respectés et soutenus dans
leur mission essentielle
alors mettez vous d'accord avec vous
même soit on les respecte
on les augmente soit on les augmente pas
et on les respecte pas mais il faut
faire un choix qui soit claire et nous
avons tenu parole en agissant pour que
l'éducation nationale redevienne en 2015
avec 65 milliards d'euros le premier
poste budgétaire de l'état et nous avons
tenu parole en engageant la création de
60000 postes couvrant tous les métiers
de l'éducation nationale alors que vous
et ça déjà été rappelé hier vous avez
supprimé au cours du quinquennat
précédent 81 mille postes d'enseignants
nous avons choisi en effet madame la
députée de revalorisées de 1,2 point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires et je le dis
clairement là aussi il y z'ont depuis
six ans largement contribué à l'effort
de redressement national
et c'est une considération légitime pour
sa sacoche qui assurent au quotidien
l'accessibilité et la qualité du service
public souvent au plus près des français
alors là aussi madame la députée moi je
suis
et au débat avec ceux qui considèrent
que l'état et les services publics sont
indispensables pour la cohésion
nationale et ceux qui comme vous
proposer la suppression de 300 mille
fonctionnaires
ce débat doit avoir lieu devant le pays
nous avons choisi une madame la députée
de consacrer oui 600 millions d'euros
dans la formation des chômeurs parce que
nous voulons tout faire pour l'emploi
oui madame la députée nous assumons
alors dit que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
le fait d'avoir pour soutenir les
agriculteurs décidé d'engager 1,3
milliard êtes vous d'accord
oui ou non c'est un débat et d'une
manière générale madame la députée il ne
s'agit pas de cadeau quelle vision quel
mépris et les agriculteurs et du service
public et des enseignants et des
fonctionnaires en général quand on parle
de cadeaux électoralisme ce pays la
france s'est construit et sa colonne
vertébrale est ainsi fait avec un état
avec des services publics
mais ça n'est pas d incarner ce sont des
hommes des femmes des agents qui
travaillent pour l'intérêt général et
pour les français
et vous avez oublié de citer mais c'est
assez curieux est assez intéressant
l'effort engagé notamment par le
ministre de l'intérieur pour soutenir
les policiers et les gendarmes dont l'un
de vos collègues parlaient et un instant
policiers et gendarmes qui viennent de
bénéficier d'une augmentation non
seulement de moyens humains 9000 postes
créés au cours de ce quinquennat alors
que vous et s'était rappelée par bernard
cazeneuve
vous en avez supprimé 13 milles mais non
seulement il ya ces moyens humains non
seulement il ya soutien matériel mais il
y a là aussi une augmentation de leur
régime indemnitaire et nous l'assumons
cela représente en effet 800 millions
d'euros
ça n'avait jamais été fait et la plupart
des syndicats le soutiennent alors oui
madame la députée j'assume et nous
assumons ses choix et le ministre de des
finances y reviendra tout à l'heure nous
le faisons avec les économies
nécessaires vous proposer la suppression
de 300 mille postes de fonctionnaires
vous proposez des économies qui ne
pourra être financée que par des
augmentations d'impôts alors
nous nous baissons les impôts et si nous
pouvons continuer nous le ferons ainsi
c'est ça la solidarité et le sérieux
budgétaire
je vous attends dans un vrai débat
aujourd'hui et demain
m